il est redouté et imprévisible ce sont
familiers qui s'apprêtent encore une
fois à transpercer la ville
en un instant le quotidien des habitants
est bousculé depuis que les attaques
russes ont repris les gens de la
capitale ont renoué avec les abris les
stations de métro servent de refuge les
sirènes aériennes retentissent presque
quotidiennement le plus souvent au petit
Dior du matin
malgré la fatigue Oxanna ne manque pas
une journée de travail pour le bien de
l'économie ukrainienne
mais la menace russe venue du ciel peut
aussi virer au cauchemar
ce bâtiment est rentré dans le sud de
Kiev percuté par un drone russe lors
d'une vague d'attaques aériennes à la
fin aimer ce qui reste de ces murs s'est
transformé en tombeau
Ivan a survécu à l'attaque et se remet
de ses blessures à l'hôpital mais son
épouse qui était dans la même pièce n'a
pas eu sa chance
se trouvait près de la fenêtre quand
l'explosion est survenue ce qui a été
fatal il a tenté de l'aider mais son
état était trop grave il est dévasté
mais en même temps reconnaissant de
l'avoir eu dans sa vie
[Musique]
nous avons eu une relation formidable
tout était parfait un peu partout Kiev
porte les marques des attaques venues
des airs depuis le début du mois de mai
seulement il y en a eu une vingtaine
Moscou cherche à épuiser les défenses
aériennes ukrainiennes et surtout à
ébranler le moral de la population
devant cette clinique de l'Est de Kiev 3
personnes ont perdu la vie dont la
petite Vicat neuf ans et sa maman tuée
par les débris tombants du ciel après
l'interception de missile russe
un deuil porté par tous les résidents du
quartier
était une enfant joyeuse et sportive une
super enfant dit sa voisine pour ajouter
au drame les victimes sont mortes alors
qu'ils attendaient à l'extérieur d'un
abri verrouillé et inaccessible
c'est une tragédie je n'ai pas de mots
dit-elle l'affaire a déclenché une vague
d'indignation dans tout le pays le
président Zelinski a ordonné une
inspection nationale des abris Antibes
dans une tentative de rassurer la
population le ministre des industries
stratégiques supervise lui-même les
inspections
mais plusieurs ne sont pas accessibles
ou en mauvaise conditions
municipaux il déplore que l'abri dans
son immeuble soit constamment
verrouillée à Kiev environ le tiers des
quelques 5000 abris antibrombe inspectés
se sont avérés et inaccessibles
à croire après un an et demi de guerre
alors que les résidents navigue entre
inquiétudes et colère les militaires eux
font de leur mieux pour défendre la
ville le lieutenant général criminosco
et le gardien du ciel de
kievirus utilisent des drones à basse
altitude pour déjouer nos défenses son
équipe on a abattu une centaine depuis
un mois la grande majorité des drones et
des missiles sont interceptés mais pas
tous
il nous faut plus de systèmes de défense
entière et explique-t-il et des avions
de chasse pour créer deux couches de
protection
pendant que l'armée se prépare à la
prochaine attaque
Ivan lui s'efforce de regarder vers
l'avant malgré le deuil
c'est un énorme choc je dois accepter ce
qui est arrivé c'est la seule façon
d'avancer il ne se fait pas d'illusions
sur les difficultés qui les attendent
son pays et lui
est fort il a beaucoup de ressources et
il n'arrêtera pas
les ukrainien n'ont pas le choix ils
essaient de vivre normalement en otage
sous leur propre ciel ici Louis Blouin
Radio-Canada qui est